SCENES OF DEVASTATION UNFOLDING
RIGHT NOW IN TURKEY AND SYRIA
AFTER WHAT IS BEING CALLED ONE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL EARTHQUAKE
TO HIT THE REGION IN A CENTURY.
>> MORE THAN 1600 PEOPLE WERE
KILLED, AND THOUSANDS WERE
INJURED AFTER THE MASSIVE QUAKE
STRUCK TURKEY'S GAZIANTEP
PROVINCE EARLIER MONDAY
MORNING.
IN A NUMBER OF PEOPLE STILL
BURIED UNDERNEATH THE BURIAL,
AND THAT NUMBER COULD RISE
DRAMATICALLY.
>> WE DO NOT KNOW HOW FAR THE
NUMBER OF DEAD AND INJURED WILL
RISE, AS THE REMOVAL WORKS
CONTINUE WITH MANY BUILDINGS IN
THE QUAKE ZONE.
OUR HOPE IS THAT WE WILL
RECOVER FROM THIS DISASTER WITH
THE LEAST LOSS OF LIFE.
>> RESCUE WORKERS FRANTICALLY
SEARCHING FOR SURVIVORS IN
BITTERLY COLD TEMPERATURES.
BUT EVEN AS THEY DO, MATER
SHOCKS ARE HITTING THE AREA.
CNN'S SCOTT MCLAIN IS FOLLOWING
DEVELOPMENTS, HE JOINS US HERE
IN LONDON WITH THE LATEST ON
THAT, AND THESE AFTERSHOCKS ARE
MASSIVE, AREN'T THEY?
>> YES, THE NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES HERE FOR RESCUE
WORKERS MAX JUST CONTINUES TO
MULTIPLY.
THESE AFTERSHOCKS, UNDER ANY
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE, HAD THERE
NOT BEEN A 7.8 OVERNIGHT, YOU
WOULD CALL THEM MASSIVE
EARTHQUAKES ON THEIR OWN.
SO YOU HAD THE 7.8, WHICH
HAPPENED AFTER 4:00 IN THE
MORNING, AND THEN JUST ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF HOURS AGO OR SO,
YOU HAD ANOTHER MAJOR, MAJOR
AFTERSHOCK THERE WAS A 7.5,
JUST TO PUT THAT INTO CONTEXT,
THAT IS THE STRONGEST
EARTHQUAKE, STRONGER EVEN THAN
THE LAST SUBSTANTIAL EARTHQUAKE
IN TURKEY, WHICH IS 1999.
THAT WAS A SEVEN POINT, FOUR
AND THAT ONE KILLED 17,000
PEOPLE, LEFT HALF 1 MILLION
PEOPLE HOMELESS.
IT JUST GIVES YOU A SENSE OF
WHAT WE ARE UP AGAINST AS THESE
RESCUE WORKERS ARE BATTLING NOT
ONLY THE CONSTANT TREMORS AND
SMALLER EARTHQUAKES, BUT ALSO
THE RISK OF MAJOR AFTERSHOCKS
LIKE THIS ONE, PLUS THE COLD
WEATHER, PLUS THE SNOW.
I JUST WANT TO SHOW YOU A PIECE
OF VIDEO THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN
NOT LONG AGO FOR MALATYA.
THIS WAS FROM THE MOST RECENT
AFTERSHOCK THERE.
THIS IS A REPORTER WITH A
TURKISH CHANNEL CALLED A NEWS,
LIVE ON AIR, WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE
CLEARLY, THEY REALIZED THAT
THERE IS MORE SHAKING, THEY
HEAR THE SOUNDS, AND START
RUNNING.
THAT'S WHY WE PLAY THE PIECE OF
VIDEO, AND I TRANSLATE WHAT THE
REPORTER SAYS.
WATCH.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> THE SOUNDS THERE MAX ARE
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING THERE.
THE REPORTER HERE IS SAYING, AS
WE ARE GOING TO THE RUBBLE, THE
SEARCH AND RESCUE EFFORTS,
THERE ARE TWO CONSECUTIVE
AFTERSHOCKS IN THE LOUD NOISE
WITH THE BUILDING YOU ARE SEEN
THAT WAS BROUGHT DOWN TO EARTH,
THERE'S LOTS OF DEPTHS, THIS
LOCAL RESIDENT HERE IS COVERED
IN DUST.
SO SOME REALLY TERRIFYING
SCENES.
WE ALSO HAVE UPDATES ON THE
NUMBER OF KILLED AND INJURED,
MORE THAN 1000 NOW IN TURKEY
WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED ACQUAINTED
AUTHORITIES.
MORE THAN 2800 BUILDINGS HAVE
BEEN DEMOLISHED.
HAVE COLLAPSED, AND SO YOU
IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENED THERE,
YOU MENTIONED THAT EACH ONE OF
THESE SITES WHERE WE ARE SEEING
THE PICTURES, MULTIPLY THAT BY
2000 IT 800, AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHAT POTENTIALLY THE
DEATH TOLL IS GOING TO BE HERE,
ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS INITIAL
EARTHQUAKE TOOK PLACE
OVERNIGHT.
THEY'RE MORE THAN 7000 INJURED,
BUT PRESIDENT ERDOGAN MADE
CLEAR EARLIER TODAY THAT THEY
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE MAY STILL BE TRAPPED
UNDERNEATH OF THE RUBBLE.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS AID COMING
IN FROM AROUND THE WORLD,
RESCUERS FROM AROUND THE WORLD,
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO TRY TO
GET THERE, BUT THESE THINGS
TAKE TIME, AND WITH THESE
BITTERLY COLD TEMPERATURES,
NOTHING CAN HAPPEN QUICKLY
ENOUGH GIVEN THAT OF COURSE IT
WOULD BE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR SOMEONE TO SURVIVE
UNDERNEATH THE RUBBLE.
VERY LIKELY BADLY INJURED IN
THESE KIND OF TEMPERATURES,
WHICH ARE RIGHT AROUND FREEZING,
FOR SIGNIFICANT PERIODS OF TIME,
MAX.
>> WE'LL JUST SEEING THAT THE
UK HAS BEEN ASKED BY THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT FOR SEARCH
AND RESCUE TEAMS, AND THEY ARE
SENDING 76 PERSONNEL APPARENTLY,
BUT THEY ARE PARTICULARLY
LOOKING FOR SEISMIC LISTENING
DEVICES, CONCRETE CUTTING, AND
BREAKING EQUIPMENT.
THIS IS THE SORT OF KIT THAT
THEY NEED IN THE NEXT FEW HOURS
REALLY, DON'T THEY, AND WHERE
THEY GET THOSE PEOPLE FROM OUT
UNDER THE RUBBLE.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND EVEN WHEN IT COMES TO MORE
BASIC THINGS LIKE THAT, LIKE
HEAVY MACHINERY TO TRY TO PICK
FOR SOME OF THE DEBRIS, IF IN
FACT THERE IS SOMEONE TRAPPED
THAT MAYBE THEY CAN GET TO,
THESE THINGS ARE READILY
AVAILABLE IN BIG CITIES LIKE
GAZIANTEP, WHICH HAS THE
HIGHEST DEATH TOLL RIGHT NOW,
200 PEOPLE KILLED, OR AT LEAST
200 PEOPLE KILLED I SHOULD SAY,
BUT ONE OF THE CONCERNS IS THAT
A LOT OF THIS EQUIPMENT PERHAPS
IS NOT FOUND AS READILY
AVAILABLE IN SOME OF THESE
SMALLER TOWNS AND VILLAGES
CLOSER TO THE EPICENTER, WHICH
IS WHERE THE SEARCH AND RESCUE
EFFORTS ARE MUCH MORE
RUDIMENTARY THAN THEY ARE IN
THE BIG CITIES.
HOPEFULLY A LOT OF THESE TOWNS
OR VILLAGES DON'T HAVE THE KIND
OF HIGH-RISES THAT WE HAVE IN
SOME OF THE BIGGER CITIES, BUT
REMEMBER, 1999 WAS A REAL WAKE
UP CALL FOR TURKEY, AND THAT IS
WHEN THEY STARTED TO REALLY GET
SMART ON BUILDING CODES AND
MAKE SURE THAT ANY NEW BUILDS
WERE ACCORDING TO EARTHQUAKE
PROOFING STANDARDS, BUT IN THE
SMALLER TOWNS AND VILLAGES,
WHERE YOU HAVE OLDER BUILDINGS,
PERHAPS NOT UP TO THE SAME KIND
OF CODES, THAT IS WHERE THERE'S
PLENTY OF CONCERN THAT THE
DEATH TOLL COULD BE EVEN HIGHER,
AND WE JUST SIMPLY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT YET, BECAUSE THE
MOBILE CONNECTIVITY OUT THERE
IT'S NOT GREAT AT THE MOMENT,
MAX.
>> OKAY SCOTT, THANK YOU.
AND SYRIA, OFFICIALS SAID AT
LEAST 592 PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN
THE QUAKE.
SYRIA STATE NEWS AGENCY SAYS
MOST OF THE DAMAGE AND DEATHS
WERE IN AND AROUND ALEPPO NEAR
SYRIA'S NORTHERN BORDER WITH
TURKEY.
THERE ARE ALSO CASUALTIES
REPORTED IN OPPOSITION HELD
TERRITORY IN SYRIA'S NORTHWEST.
RESCUE CREWS ACROSS THE REGION
ARE DESPERATELY TRYING TO
SEARCH OR REACH THOSE STUCK
UNDER THE RUBBLE OF FALLEN
BUILDINGS.
EARLIER, THEY MAKE YOU PULL
THIS YOUNG BOY OUT FROM THE
RUBBLE IN THE CITY OF IDLIB.
SALMA HAS BEEN MODELED --
MONITORING ALL OF THE SYRIAN
MOVEMENTS.
SADLY, THEY HAVE EXPERIENCE,
GROUPS LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING
IN THESE SITUATIONS.
>> THIS IS AN ABSOLUTELY
CATASTROPHIC EVENT FOR A
COUNTRY THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
DEVASTATED BY MORE THAN A
DECADE OF WAR, MAX.
YOUR FROM A COLLEAGUE SCOTT
ABOUT HOW TURKISH AUTHORITIES
HAVE REALLY BEEN PREPARING FOR
A HUGE EARTHQUAKE MOUNT FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BUILD UP
BILLING CODES, THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
SAFE.
IN SYRIA, THE EXACT OPPOSITE
HAS BEEN HAPPENING.
THERE'S BEEN A CIVIL WAR THAT
IS LITERALLY RATTLED THE
COUNTRY, DESTROYED ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE, TARGETED
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS.
AND YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
THE CIVIL CONFLICT IS VERY MUCH
PLAYING OUT HERE ON THE GROUND
AS THIS EARTHQUAKE HAPPENS IN
ITS AFTERMATH, YOU HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT AUTHORITIES ON THE
GROUND.
YOU HAVE THE REGIME CONTROLLED
AREAS, A GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED
AREAS, THEY RECEIVING HELP OF
COURSE FROM THE, MASKS AND
REBEL HELD AREAS NORTH LIKE
PLACES LIKE IDLIB, WHERE THEY
ARE ENTIRELY RELIANT ON REBEL
FORCES PROVIDING HELP,
VOLUNTEERS LIKE THE WHITE
HELMETS TO PULL PEOPLE OUT FROM
UNDER THE RUBBLE, BUT THESE
VOLUNTEERS, MASKS, THEY
THEMSELVES NEED HELP.
ONE OF THEM MADE IN APPEAL, AS
WHITE HOME AND RESCUE WORKERS
WERE TRYING TO PULL PEOPLE OUT
OF THE RUBBLE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> VERY DIFFICULT TEST FOR US,
WE NEED HELP, WE NEED THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING TO HELP US TO SUPPORT
US.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS A DISASTER.
WE HELP FROM EVERYONE TO SAVE
OUR PEOPLE.
>> YOU CAN HEAR THE EMOTION IN
HIS VOICE THERE, MAX.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY A DESPERATE
AND DEVASTATING SITUATION FOR A
SYRIAN COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
TRAUMATIZE, AS I MENTIONED, BY
THIS CONFLICT.
MANY PEOPLE ARE WAKING UP AND
WONDERING IF IT WAS WARPLANES
WHEN IT REALLY WAS AN
EARTHQUAKE, AND I HAVE MORE
AFTERSHOCKS COMING FOR THE
TRAUMATIZED CHILDREN LIVING IN
THESE AREAS WITH VERY LITTLE
RESOURCES, VERY LITTLE HELP,
AND WE HAVE IMAGES TO SHOW YOU
OF THE HOSPITALS THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY OVERWHELMED.
WE SAW PICTURES ON SOCIAL MEDIA
OF THE DEAD LITERALLY LYING ON
THE FLOOR OF HOSPITALS LEADING
OUT UNTREATED BECAUSE THERE IS
NO CARE TO GIVE THEM.
BODY BAGS PILING UP AGAIN IN
THESE CLINICS.
AND HERE THERE AGAIN FROM MY
COLLEAGUE SCOTT ABOUT HOW THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS
ALREADY OFFERING HELP TO TURKEY,
ONLY TRYING TO BRING THE
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED.
HE WILL NOT BE THE SAME CASE
FOR SYRIA.
THERE IS SIMPLY NOT THE ACCESS
THERE.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, DAMASCUS,
GOVERNMENT IS SANCTIONED BY THE
WEST BECAUSE OF ITS INVOLVEMENT
IN THIS CONFLICT.
SO THERE WILL BE NO DIRECT LINE
OF COMMUNICATION, THERE WILL BE
NOBODY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PICKING UP THE PHONE AND ASKING
PRESIDENT BASHAR AL-ASSAD WHAT
TO DO.
THIS WILL VERY MUCH BE
DEPENDENT ON THE PEOPLE LIVING
THERE, RELYING ON THEMSELVES IN
THESE AFTERSHOCKS COMING ONE
AFTER ANOTHER IN THIS ALREADY
DEVASTATED AREA, AND EVEN NORTH
OF THAT BORDER, INSIDE TURKEY,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS
OF SYRIAN REFUGEES LIVING
THEIR.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THEIR
SAFE SPACE, MAX, AND THAT
ABSOLUTELY IS DEVASTATED NOW.